[Musique]
siffle c'est sûr c'est une paria c'est une
orpheline c'est cette mystérieuse
badass sauvage elle a été laissée pour morte
elle aimerait vivre dans un monde avec nous
une limite de personne de moins il a assassiné ma
mère
bonjour elle veut sa vengeance
elle n'est pas votre héros typique  mais l'
histoire devient plus grande que son oreille et
je te cherche depuis longtemps
Hester ne veut pas dire faire confiance à beaucoup de
gens lentement nous commençons à voir ce qu'il y a en
dessous de toi sûr que tu veux faire ça
je dois
j'ai grandi  avec le bruit des moteurs je n'ai
jamais rien connu d'autre
au début de ce film Chalmers un
personnage très protégé je pensais que tu
avais des projets d'être aviateur histoire c'est
plus mon truc
tom a passé toute sa vie à Londres
il a une bravoure admirable c'est
une sorte de sommeil mais il n'a jamais
mis les pieds sur le sol
blanc basson le téléphone il a été
plongé dans cette folie
tu ne me laisserais pas taire il n'y a
pas jusqu'à ce qu'il tombe dans cette incroyable
aventure il peut pleinement réaliser son
rêve  m
le monde a changé
Valentin est vénéré comme un héros à Londres
nous sommes Londres mais il a un côté sombre
30e Valentin il a un très bon
nom il pense que le monde est dans un tel
état qu'il se tue il
meurt si quelqu'un a besoin de choquer  lui, c'est
un homme qui ne voit le monde que dans ses propres
termes et si cela signifie que beaucoup de gens
meurent, ce n'est pas grave, ce genre de personnages
me fait beaucoup peur le grand jeu de
survie c'est échec et mat
il veut être à l'avant-garde vous beaucoup
mieux  monde mais vous vous donnez un coup de pied
parce que vous ne réalisez pas à quel point il peut
vraiment être un homme qui contrôle cela contrôle
le monde, vous pouvez l'arrêter
comme pour montrer à l'homme qu'il l'arrête - Lantern
[Music]
tout est quelqu'un avec qui il ne faut pas
jouer  type de héros très différent,
elle est cette leader impitoyable et intrépide
, elle est la leader de la
ligue d'attraction et l'ennemi numéro un,
tout est très protecteur de Hester, nous
devons arrêter Londres avant qu'elle ne
nous détruise ce soir, nous nous battons et un fan c  se
réconcilie avec les intentions de Valentin
et Sue essaie toujours de les arrêter une fois que nous sommes entrés,
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
M'Lynn Jesus est assis dans un monde que nous n'avons
jamais vu
[Musique]
c'est un monde merveilleusement imaginé qui
a été réalisé par Peter Jackson et
son équipe l'étendue de la vision qu'ils ont
apportée au Seigneur des Anneaux ils
vont apporter la même chose aux
moteurs mortels les villes déplacent en fait
leurs villes de traction leur message les
grandes villes dans des villes plus petites à
Londres comme l'une des plus grandes qu'elles  sont
en mission pour traquer une autre ville
et la magie au cœur de cette histoire est l'
histoire
quand nous le devons pour la première fois, elle est cette
mystérieuse histoire de dur à cuire sauvage
en mission pour se
venger et tuer la personne qui a
assassiné sa mère qu'elle aimerait  vivre
dans un monde avec nous une personne de moins dedans
Valentine et c'est Valentine c'est
pour ma
mère ça va les choses ne se passent pas comme
prévu les moteurs c'est l'histoire de deux personnes
qui se percutent
demandez bonjour  m ce que vous avez épousé ma mère,
il y a des personnages et leur
voyage au-delà de la main du destin les a
infligés
Tom et Hester sont forcés dans une
situation où ils doivent compter l'un sur
l'autre pour survivre à la médecine c'est
génial que nous ayons un personnage comme l'
histoire Shaw  qui est si sauvage et si
motivé qu'il est trop court pour s'arrêter jusqu'à ce que je sois
transformé il y a eu tellement de moments de
pure joie de travailler dans un
monde aussi fantastique votre mère Jeff a trouvé quelque chose de
dangereux nous avons eu la chance d'écrire un
très grand mystère précis dans le
la portée et l'imagination de cette chose
je vais être aussi étonné par ce film est
le public un homme qui contrôle ce
choix le monde
pas si nous l'arrêtons il s'agit de quelque
chose de plus grand que juste sa vengeance
tu es sûr que tu veux faire ça  Je dois
quelque chose que j'ai toujours voulu mentionner Je
vais passer deux ans à produire notre
film
Il doit y avoir quelque chose que je ne t'ai jamais
vu